[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشروع اليمين الاسرائيلي لبناء دوله
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومنع
دوله للفلسطينيين اخذ دفعه عمليه ومعنويه
مصادره الاداره المدنيه التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي من يد وزير الدفاع واعطائها
لحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الاستيطانيه
المتطرف لا يضع القطه في حراسه اللبن فقط
وفق مراقبين بل يحول محاولات ضم الضفه
لاسرائيل من زاحفه الى سريعه
للمستوطنين وهي محاوله لاحاله القانون
الاسرائيلي على المستوطنين في المناطق
الفلسطينيه بدون ضمن الحالي لهذا هناك
معارضه قويه من المؤسسات الامنيه لتبيعات
ذلك ميدانيا وقانونيا ودبلوماسيه
خطه العمل لحزب المستوطنين هي تكثيف
البناء الاستيطاني في المستوطنات القائمه
وتحويل اكثر من 70 بؤره شيطانيه عشوائيه
الى مستوطنات تتبناها الحكومه الى جانب
حمله هدم واسعه النطاق للبناء الفلسطيني
في مناطق الجيم تمهيدا لضمها ما قد يفجر
ازمه مع الاداره الامريكيه والمجتمع
الدولي فضلا عن تفجير الوضع الميداني اكثر
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله صعبه يركز فيها
اليمين المتطرف الذي سوف يحكم اسرائيل على
على الضم وعلى التهويت في داخل مدينه
القدس وايضا على توزيع مخططات الظلام
ناسيه مع ان هناك اصوات من الوزراء
القادمين همم ينادون لتشكيل وزاره مختصه
بتهجير الفلسطينيين وفقا للقانون الدولي
لا سياده الاسرائيل على ضفه الغربيه
والقدس الشرقيه وتسيطر عليها بعمليه
قتاليه مؤقته اي ان وزير الدفاع
يدير الوضع لهذا فان ادخال السيطره
المدنيه للحكومه رسميه تعني بدء الضم
الفعلي للضفه الغربيه في حكومه متطرفه
يبدو فيها نتنياهو الجناح اليسريه سيشهد
مشروع الاستيطان انتعاشا وتمددا الى جانب
المعالجه الامنيه الاسرائيليه فقط للقضيه
الفلسطينيه بحيث لا تتسع خريطه الواقع
لقيام دوله فلسطينيه ما قد ينهي حل
للدولتين كما تخشى دوائر استراتيجيه في
اسرائيل اما الى قيام نظام ابارتيد او الى
دوله ثانيه القوميه زياد حلبي العربيه
الضفه الغربيه المحتله